now that you've explained the six stages
and we've already talked about stage one
the set up can you also talk about what
happens in stage two which is still in
Act one yeah so as I said at about the
ten percent point of the story something
that's never happened to the hero before
is going to happen and that's the
opportunity it can be something good
meeting the person of their dreams if
it's a romantic comedy let's say it can
be something terrible like the first
body and a serial killer movie is
discovered or the spaceship that the
aliens are landing on earth in shows up
whether it's good or bad though it's
going to be something that forces the
hero into stage two a new situation and
in this stage the primary goal of the
character is to figure out what's going
on I've entered this new world sometimes
in movies it's even a change of
geography to go back to quite an old
movie now Thelma and Louise it's when
they leave town and go off to spend the
weekend in that some guy's cabin or
something like that
in the firm it's when he takes the job
with bendini lambert & locke and he and
his wife head to Memphis
it could be geographical change it might
not be but something they're in a new
situation and they have to figure out
what am I doing here what are the rules
of this world I'm entered what is
expected of me or how am I going to deal
with the discovery of that body or what
am I gonna do about this this this
person I just met a movie that I really
enjoyed a lot this year is I in the sky
and we meet our hero Helen Mirren you
know waking up and we see her living our
everyday life we see that she's in the
military and so on she gets a call and
when she gets to the base or whatever it
is she discovers that they have found or
they have confirmed that a group of
terrorists particularly these two
Americans have shown up and she's been
doggin after them so she's got to figure
out okay how are we going to go about
following them or capturing them once
they're all together and she
trying to figure out what do I do now on
the inner journey level in stage one we
see the character living fully in his
identity okay like I mentioned Will
Hunting and Good Will Hunting or if you
take a character like hitch who is also
had his heart broken so he's shut down
and he'll he'll help other people fall
in love but he doesn't believe in love
for himself he's stuck in stage two the
character is still in his identity still
fully protected that the character would
get a glimpse of what living fully
living in his essence might be like so
that's in hitch when he first meets
Albert Brennaman the Kevin James
character who for all his schlubby
personality is way more courageous and
way more understanding of the value of
falling in love than hitches so he gets
just a look at what that might be like
he doesn't really register but we
recognize okay this is what this person
needs to learn we recognize early on in
the story this is the journey this
character needs to go on on the inside
and then at the end of stage two comes
what I call the change of plans
another key turning point another thing
happens that has never happened before
and that's going to move the character
from figuring out what's going on to
formulating a goal that visible goal and
taking the first steps to achieve it so
when that happens let's go back to I in
the sky what happens there is they
discover that these terrorists have
moved to a different location the
location they can't go in and capture
the terrorists because it will create
you know chaos outside the only way they
can stop them is to use a drone fire a
missile and bomb them just you know kill
them blow them into oblivion so now the
outer motivation for Helen Mirren
becomes she wants to use or use a
missile on a drone to kill the
terrorists in
building and the rest of the movie will
be her pursuit of that goal and all of
the obstacles she will encounter in
trying to get there all of the conflict
and I should mention this probably
should have been earlier in the
interview but I'll say it now I began
this by saying the primary goal of any
storyteller is to elicit emotion one
thing that's critical to understand is
emotion grows out of conflict not desire
so the more you can build up the
obstacles the characters have to face
the more emotionally involving the story
will be why is that is that because of
identification because we all kind of
relate it back to something that's
happened to us and if do we see someone
struggling even more than we are then it
becomes more interesting holds our
attention yeah partly it's that I mean
the the why exactly conflict locks us in
emotionally it's I believe actually
because our brains are wired for that
going all the way back to evolution
because we had to be alert to when we
were caveman or wherever we evolved from
then we had to be alert to danger
so emotion is always going to be
heightened when there's a moment of some
obstacle or conflict or danger and that
has gotten so engrained into our brains
that it spilled over and it's true for
stories and narrative as well so it's
almost a visceral biological reaction to
conflict but that's why people go to the
movies that's why they read novels
that's why they go to plays or watch
television so they can have an emotional
experience so that means we go to see
conflict desire is just there to move
the story forward but it's the obstacles
that are going to grab us and hold us in
so when it comes to empathy you notice
that the things I mentioned that could
create empathy let's say sympathy
that's conflict that the character is
experienced in the past we feel sorry
for them because they're poor or they
had a tough childhood or we find out
their spouses just died as in Sleepless
in Seattle or whatever okay or another
way is you put a character in jeopardy
that's conflict that's coming in the
future that they're in danger of getting
on the Titanic which is going to sink or
they're in danger of encountering the
villain that was introduced before they
were in the movie or whatever it might
be or I said if a character is likable
good-hearted generous that's how they
help others deal with conflict so the
empathy the emotional connection between
hero and or between audience and hero or
reader and hero also grows out of the
conflict that they are subjected to or
were subjected to or will be so that the
reader recognizes that and that gets
them more emotionally involved in the
hero
you